in their minds they were revolutionaries
david cameron and businessman lex
greensell transforming the way business
is done here in saudi arabia
lex greensell advised cameron in
government and when the former pm
left number 10 he went to work for
greensell's finance firm
which was meant to help companies pay
their bills on time
that dream collapsed in march today
david cameron published his texts and
emails
revealing the excruciating ends he went
to lobbying government
as the firm's problems grew and grew
last year
at the beginning of april david cameron
texted the most senior civil servant at
the treasury
tom scholar saying he was genuinely
baffled that green sill was being
rejected for financial help
calling the situation bonkers and that
he was now about to phone the chancellor
and michael gove everyone he went on to
text michael gove recognizing he was
manically busy at the height of the
pandemic which was bloody hard working
extremely well
but asking whether the cabinet minister
had a moment for a word and that mr
cameron was on this number
and very free still getting nowhere at
the end of april
cameron texts the chancellor again
asking whether he could try and give it
another nudge to get it over the line
no success with him in june cameron went
down the chain of command
texting one of rishi sunak's aides
richard sharp asking whether there were
any updates on his talks with the
chancellor today
lex greenzel appeared in public for the
first time just as the watchdog
announced it was launching an inquiry
into whether criminal activity had taken
place
he began with an apology i bear complete
responsibility for the collapse of
greensville capital
to all of those affected by this
i am truly sorry but many more questions
followed
are you a fraudster
no mr connor i am not and how much has
the firm's collapse cost the public
what has been the loss to the taxpayer
it has been no loss to the taxpayer
why did you have david cameron as an
adviser
to your company the green cell affair
is the tale of how a little-known
businessman dazzled
the most senior politicians and
officials for years
with his claims that he'd invented a new
way of doing business
now that collapse costing thousands of
jobs potentially billions of pounds
of your money and a criminal inquiry
into whether someone broke the law
the question is just how could so many
people
especially david cameron let themselves
get dragged into this
david cameron rinsed through his web of
contacts for green cell
whatsapps to richie sunak a meeting with
matt hancock text to nadine zahawi and
michael gove
then to jesse norman john glenn he tried
treasury officials tom scholar and
charles
roxborough and eventually mid-level
political aid sheridan westlake in
number 10 and richard sharp in the
treasury
how one company got its demands heard
like this has rung alarm bells
there's a lesson here you know that we
need to have double
the degree of scrutiny and control that
we thought we had in order to make sure
that
best amounts of public money isn't
wasted when people have been at the top
of the government
they should walk away from it david
cameron will have to explain why he
didn't walk away
on thursday when he appears before mps
sam coates sky news